افادت مراسله الجزيره قبل قليل بان قصفا
مدفعيا اسرائيليا يستهدف الاطراف الشماليه
والشرقيه لمدينه غزه كما افادت باندلاع
اشتباكات بين المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال في
مخيمات وسط القطاع تنضم الينا من غلاف غزه
مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان ماذا في
تفاصيل ما افدت به منذ
قليل نعم فيض انتقلنا من المناطق الشماليه
وهناك ايضا كنا نسمع ضوي انفجارات طيله
الوقت منذ ان وصلنا الى المناطق المقابله
لمنطقتي بيت لاهيه وبيت حانون و قد قد
يشير ذلك الى بع قصف مدفعي يطال بعض
المواقع هناك ولكن ايضا هناك عمليات تفجير
مستمره لبعض المباني والمنازل في منطقه
الشمال وراي ايضا تحركات كثيره لاليات
عسكريه لجرافات ايضا تابعه لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تقوم
بالعمل في المناطق المحاذيه للشريط
الحدودي داخل الشريط الحدودي هذه المناطق
الوسطى حاليا مقابل منطقه جحر الديك وهذا
الاستهداف قبل قليل نرى اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد من تلك المناطق جراء القصف
المتواصل بالاضافه الى القصف المدفعي الان
فقد سمعنا ايضا كما يبدو غاره جويه
استهدفت هذه المواقع تحديدا في جنوب مدينه
غزه منطقه جحر الديك والمناطق المحاذيه
لها من المخيمات
الوسطى في مدينه غزه هناك ايضا يتحدث
الناطق العسكري باسم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بانه يواصل عملياته في هذا هذه
المخيمات مخيمات البريج والنصيرات
والمغازي ايضا
وهذا جزء من هذه المعارك الدائره في تلك
المواقع الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل قصفه
وعملياته العسكريه في تلك المواقع كما نرى
هذه كانت غاره جويه قبل قليل فقط قبل
دقائق معدوده استهدفت هذه
المناطق المحاد تماما لمنطقه جحر الديك
وسط
قطاع غزه لكن ايضا نسمع فد اصوات ابعد من
ذلك للقصف المدفعي هناك قصف مدفعي ايضا
الان هذا هذا ايضا الان عمليه اخرى من
عمليات القصف المتواصله لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في داخل قطاع غزه اعتقد ان هذه
هذه سحب الدخان وهذه انفجارات ان كنتم
تسمعونها جراء
اي ربما غاره جويه اخرى تستهدف مواقع هذه
تنبعث ربما من مخيم البريج تحديدا
اي اذا هذا هو القصف المتواصل الذي نرصده
من هذه المناطق وكما تشاهدون سحب الدخان
متواصله بفعل هذه الغارات وهذا ال القصف
لكن ايضا هذا القصف المدفعي تحديدا يتواصل
في منطقه الاحياء الشماليه لمدينه غزه
تحديدا حيي الدرج والتفاح رغم انه قبل
قليل فقط فدا اصدر الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي بيانا يقول فيه او ينقل فيه عن
قائد اللواء 460 في الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي
خاض هذه المعارك في هذه المناطق في حيي
الدرج والتفاح يقول بان مهمه هذه اللواء
في هذه المناطق في حيي الدرج والتفاح
استكملت هذا ال اليوم يوم امس ويوم امس
الاول كان يتحدث الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي عن هذه الاحياء بانها بحسب
وصفه المعاقل الاخيره لحركه حماس في
المناطق الشماليه بعد ان كان قد اعلن بانه
سيطر او احكم سيطرته الناريه على مناطق
متعدده في الشمال مثل بيت حنون وبيت لاهيا
وجباليا وقال بانه يخ خود هذا القتال هذه
هذه المسيره هذه مسيره لنقل جنود مصابين
اذا هذه
مسيره مروحيه عفوا عفوا هذه
مروحيه من فرق
الانقاذ 6 س
ت اذا فد هذه مروحيه عسكريه تابعه لسلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي لما يعرف بفرقه فرقه
الانقاذ
669 يبدو بانها او من المؤكد تنقل مصابين
من جنود من مناطق محاذيا في قطاع غزه
باتجاه مستشفيات
اسرائيليه
اي نعم اذا كانت هذه المروحيه
العسكريه كما يبدو بان ما رايناه ايضا من
غطاء ناري قبل قليل في تلك المناطق التي
حلقت من فوقها هذه المروحيه كانت ربما
لاسناد القوات على الارض
ولتغطية ما بين مروحيات عسكريه بالعاده
تتدخل لنقل مصابين جنود في حاله خطره
بينما ايضا كنا قد رصدنا في الايام
الاخيره الماضيه سيارات اسعاف عسكريه تقل
ايضا مصابين من ارض المعركه من داخل قطاع
غزه باتجاه المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
وبالتالي هذا يبدو ما تم نقله الان ربما
حالات خطره
للجنود الى ال المستشفيات يوم امس فقط
قالت صحيفه هارتس نقلا عن مصادر في الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه في المعركه التي دارت في
منطقه شمال غزه وقتل فيها احد ال الجنود
كانت هنا سجلت هذه المعركه 11 ع اصابه
لجنود في المناطق الشماليه من بينهم
جنديين اصيبا بحالات خطره وهذا فقط يدلل
على ضراوه المعكر المعارك عفوا حتى عندما
يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه احكم سيطرته
الناريه على المناطق الشماليه ما زلنا نرى
بان هناك تسجيل لاصابات خطيره وايضا لمقتل
جنود في المناطق الجنوبيه الشماليه
بالاضافه الى ما يحدث في المناطق الجنوبيه
تحديدا في منطقه خان يونس يتحدث عن معارك
ايضا ضاريه وتقدم بطيء لقواته في محيط
منطقه خان يونس فدا شكرا لك نجوان مراسه
الجزيره من غلاف غزه